♪ ♪
>> Bret: THE TOP MAN AT THE
PENTAGON RIGHT NOW SINCE CHINA
IS THE BIGGEST THREAT TO THE
U.S.
ACTING DEFENSE SECRETARY PATRICK
SHANAHAN SPOKE WITH ME IN HIS
FIRST INTERVIEW WITH THE SPACE
SYMPOSIUM IN COLORADO SPRINGS
SPRINGS.
HE TALKED UP THE NEW SPACE
FORCE.
I STARTED BY ASKING HIM ABOUT
THE DEATHS OF THREE AMERICAN
MARINES FROM A ROADSIDE BOMBING
IN AFGHANISTAN ON MONDAY.
A MAJOR DISCONNECT, THE TELE-
BAND IS TAKING CREDIT FOR THAT
ATTACK EVEN AS THE U.S. IS
SITTING DOWN WITH THE LEADERS
FOR PEACE TALKS TO END THE WAR.
>> THIS IS THE HARDEST PART OF
MY JOB.
ICE ON THE CONDOLENCES TO THE
FAMILIES OF THE FRIENDS OF THOSE
SERVICE MEMBERS WHO LOST THEIR
LIVES.
THEY GAVE THE ULTIMATE SACRIFICE
FOR WHICH WE CAN NEVER REPAY.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE SITUATION,
WE ARE EXECUTING THE SOUTH ASIA
STRATEGY IN THE SOUTH ASIA
STRATEGY REALLY SPEAKS TO
RECONCILIATION WITH THE TALIBAN
AND RECONCILIATION COMES ABOUT
FROM PUTTING PRESSURE ON THEM.
WHAT YOU SEE THE CASUALTIES OF
WAR, AND PARALLEL THERE IS A
PEACE NEGOTIATION PROCESS AND
PROBABLY THE BEST POSSIBILITY
FOR PEACE.
>> 14,000 U.S. TROOPS.
IT IS YOUR MANDATE TO CUT THAT?
>> OUR MANDATE IS TO EXECUTE THE
SOUTH ASIA STRATEGY, PURE AND
SIMPLE.
>> IS 14,000 A GOOD NUMBER?
>> WE DON'T TALK TROOP MOVEMENTS
AND TROOP LEVELS.
>> IS THERE HOPE THAT THIS WILL
COME TO A RESOLUTION?
>> I AM HOPEFUL.
THIS IS A REAL POSSIBILITY FOR
PEACE.
AS I MENTIONED EARLIER, WE ARE
DRIVING DOWN TWO TRACKS.
>> WE ARE HERE AT THE SPACE
SYMPOSIUM.
IT IS A BIG PART OF WHAT YOU ARE
DOING.
>> WE HAVE A $19 TRILLION
ECONOMY, OUR MILITARY RUNS ON
SPACE.
IT IS VITALLY IMPORTANT AND A
CRITICAL DOMAIN JUST LIKE AIR,
LAND AND SEA.
THE EXPECTATION IS OVER THE NEXT
20 YEARS IT WILL BECOME --
THE SPACE INDUSTRY WILL BECOME A
TRILLION DOLLAR A YEAR BUSINESS.
THERE IS A RISK AND DANGER AND
SPACE AND THAT IS REALLY THE
CREATION OF THE SPACE COURSE.
CHINESE AND RUSSIANS ARE
DEPLOYING CAPABILITY THAT PUT
OUR ECONOMY AND OUR MILITARY AT
RISK IN A TIME OF CRISIS.
>> Bret: CRITICS WOULD SAY YOU
WERE GIVEN THE U.S. AIR FORCE
DIFFERENT UNIFORMS?
>> WE ARE CONSOLIDATING ACROSS
TEN DIFFERENT ORGANIZATIONS INTO
A SINGLE STRUCTURE SO WE CAN
MOVE MORE QUICKLY IN THIS VERY
COMPLEX DOMAIN.
>> Bret: WHAT DOES HE THING
USED BY THE MOST TIME ON?
ACTING DEFENSE SECRETARY?
>> THE FUTURE.
>> Bret: HOW SO?
>> THE ONGOING OPERATIONS ARE
ENORMOUSLY COMPLEX.
IT HAS BEEN OVER 30 YEARS WE
MODERNIZED, CHINA IS MODERNIZIN
MODERNIZING.
WE NEED TO AS A COUNTRY
MODERNIZE OUR MILITARY.
I SPEND MORE AND MORE TIME
REALLY LAYING THE FOUNDATION AND
PUTTING THAT CAPABILITY IN
PLACE.
>> Bret: DID JIM MATTIS GIVE
YOU ANY ADVICE?
>> HIS ADVICE IS ALWAYS STEADY
AS SHE GOES, EYES ON THE BOAT.
>> Bret: HAS A BIT HARD TO
TAKE OVER FROM HIM?
>> THOSE ARE BIG SHOES TO FILL,
BUT WE HAVE THE RIGHT RESOURCES.
WE ARE IN A PERIOD OF EXECUTION.
>> Bret: DOES THE ACTING
DEFECT
AFFECT YOU?
>> MY MOTHER ASKS ME THIS
QUESTION, WHAT WILL YOU BE
NOMINATED?
WHAT I TELL HER IS, IT IS AN
HONOR AND A PRIVILEGE TO SERVE
OUR COUNTRY.
I WILL SERVE IN ANY CAPACITY THE
PRESIDENT SEES FIT.
I DON'T WAKE UP IN THE MORNING
AND THINK ABOUT WHETHER I WILL
BE NOMINATED.
I DO THE JOB.
>> Bret: DO YOU THINK YOUR
TIME IS RAISING THIS HAS BEEN
SLOWED UP?
>> I'M GLAD YOU BROUGHT THAT UP.
WHEN CONGRESS ASKED ME WHAT I BE
OPEN TO AN INVESTIGATION WITHOUT
HESITATION I SAID ABSOLUTELY.
I AM FULLY COOPERATING WITH THE
IG.
FIRST OF ALL, WHEN I JOINED THE
ADMINISTRATION I SOLD EVERY
FINANCIAL INTEREST WITH THAT
COMPANY.
I WANT TO STEP FURTHER, EVERY
INTEREST IN A DIFFERENT
SELECTOR.
THIS IS A POINT I WANT TO MAKE
VERY CLEAR.
I AM NOT BIASED TOWARDS THAT
COMPANY.
I AM BIASED TOWARDS PERFORMANCE
AND BIAS TOWARDS PERFORMANCE FOR
THE U.S. GOVERNMENT AND FOR THE
TAXPAYER AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
THE WAR FIGHTER.
I AM AN EQUAL OPPORTUNITY CRITI
CRITIC.
IF I SEE UNDERPERFORMANCE THAT I
CALL IT THE WAY I SEE IT.
THAT IS WHAT THE WAR FIGHTER
EXPECTS AND THAT IS WHAT THEY
DESERVE.
>> Bret: YOU YOU HAVE NEVER
FAVORITE BOEING AND YOUR CURRENT
JOB?
>> I HAVE NEVER FAVORED BOEING
AND I NEVER WILL.
>> Bret: ABOUT THE REPORT TO
BE CLEAR, DO YOU THINK THE
REACTION TO IT ON CAPITOL HILL
HAS BEEN POLITICALLY MOTIVATED?
>> WE WILL SEE.
I KNOW I HAVE NOT MADE ANY
DECISIONS IN FAVOR OF BOEING ANY
WORK I'VE DONE IS TO DRIVE WASTE
OUT OF THE PROGRAMS WE CAN
DELIVER THE CAPABILITY OF OUR
MEN WOMEN DESERVE.
A SAVINGS THAT THE TAXPAYERS
EXPECT.
>> Bret: IS RUSSIA OR CHINA
THE BIGGER THREAT TO THE
UNITED STATES?
>> CHINA.
CHINA'S THREAT ECONOMICALLY AND
DIPLOMATICALLY, IT IS TIME WE
ADDRESS SOME OF THESE ISSUES.
MILITARIZATION OF THE SOUTH
CHINA SEA, THE COMMUNIST CHINESE
PARTY LAUNCHING CYBER ATTACKS
AGAINST THE U.S.
THEFT OF INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY
AND A SIGNIFICANT EXPANSION OF
MILITARY CAPABILITY.
IT IS A WORLD WE NEED TO
CONFRONT.
>> Bret: WILL AMERICA EVER BE
ABLE TO TRULY PROTECT AMERICANS
FROM CYBER THREATS, FROM
COUNTRIES AND INDIVIDUALS?
>> WE WILL.
IT IS NOT TOMORROW.
IF YOU ASK ME WHAT KEEPS ME UP
AT NIGHT WHICH I'M SURE YOU
WILL, IT IS HYPER.
WHAT I WOULD TELL YOU IS THE
DEPARTMENT IS AGGRESSIVELY
ADDRESSING THAT THREAT.
ACROSS NOT JUST THE DEPARTMENT
OF DEFENSE, BUT CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WORKING WITH
OUR SUPPLIERS, ALLIES AND
PARTNERS.
>> Bret: SHOULD THE U.S.
MILITARY BE DEPLOYED AT THE
SOUTHERN BORDER?
>> THE MISSION AT THE BORDER IS
NOT A YOU A NEW ONE.
WE SUPPORTED THE BUSH
ADMINISTRATION AND THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
THE BUSH ADMINISTRATION WE HAD
OVER 6,000 TROOPS DEPLOYED.
>> Bret: THE PRESIDENT
OBVIOUSLY FOCUSES ON THE BORDER
PRETTY EXTENSIVELY.
>> THE SITUATION THERE IS
DETERIORATING.
>> Bret: KRISTA TILSON WAS ON,
DIFFERENT STORIES BEHIND THE
SCENES ABOUT THAT, BUT THERE WAS
REPORTED TENSION BETWEEN THE
PRESIDENT OF A SECRETARY.
DID YOU SEE THAT FIRST HAND?
>> I SAW A LOT OF INTENSITY TO
SOLVE A PROBLEM.
THAT IS NOT TENSION, THIS IS A
VERY FOCUSED EFFORT.
WE ARE ALL FEELING THE PRESSURE
TO SOLVE THE SITUATION DOWN AT
THE BORDER, IT IS AN EMERGENCY.
IF YOU HAVE LOTS OF INTENSE
DISCUSSIONS OF THE WHITE HOUSE
BECAUSE THESE ARE SERIOUS ISSUES
AND THEY ATTENTION.
>> Bret: TO FEEL LIKE THE
POLICY WILL CHANGE NOW THAT
THERE IS A CHANGE IN THE
LEADERSHIP?
>> WE HAVE WORKED WITH THE
ACTING SECRETARY, THE NEW ACTING
SECRETARY I'M CONFIDENT YOU'LL
BE ABLE TO CONTINUE TO SOLVE
PROBLEMS.
>> Bret: THIS DECISION ABOUT
IRAN DESIGNATED THE GUARD, A
TERRORIST ORGANIZATION.
DOES THAT CREATE PROBLEMS FOR
YOU AND U.S. TROOPS ON THE
GROUND IN IRAQ?
>> THEY ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
DEATH OF U.S. SERVICE MEMBERS.
THIS IS A POLICY DECISION TO
HAVE NONMILITARY EFFECTS PUT
PRESSURE ON THE IRANIAN ECONOMY.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK IN IRAQ
TO STRENGTHEN SECURITY FORCES.
WE RECOGNIZE THEIR SOVEREIGNTY.
IT IS OUR RULE AND COUNTRY TO
BUILD SECURITY AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO DO THAT.
>> Bret: NOW THAT HE IS
ESSENTIALLY A TERRORIST, WILL
YOU BE TARGETING HIM?
>> WE WILL USE SANCTIONS AND
APPROPRIATE MECHANISMS THAT COME
ALONG WITH THE DESIGNATION AS
APPROPRIATE.
>> Bret: WHICH INCLUDES
TARGETING SOMEONE?
WHAT IS YOUR RELATIONSHIP WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP?
>> I HAVE A GOOD RELATIONSHIP
WITH HIM.
HE IS VERY DEMANDING AS YOU KNOW
THAT HE IS VERY ENGAGING.
>> Bret: WHEN YOU HEAR CRITICS
ON TV SAY THAT HE IS
DISCONNECTED, SNAPPED, LOSING
HIS MARBLES.
THEY SAY ALL KINDS OF THINGS ON
DIFFERENT CABLE CHANNELS.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO THAT?
YOU SAID IN THOSE MEETINGS.
HOW WAS YOUR REACTION AND
INTERACTION WITH THE PRESIDENT?
>> HE IS ENGAGED.
HE SUPPORTS US AND HOW WE SHOULD
DEFEND AMERICA.
WE HAVE EXTRAORDINARY BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT FROM CONGRESS.
WE HAVE STRONG, STRONG
LEADERSHIP FROM THE WHITE HOUSE.
WE ARE MAKING THE CHANGES